- The biggest poison
in us is regret.
It's poison.
And I push so hard,
so hard, and will
through my vehicle
which isn't meditation,
which isn't health and wellness,
which isn't non-profit.
My vehicle is business.
I can't help it.
It's what I love.
I love building businesses.
Love competing with you,
I want to beat you.
I love that game.
But through that vehicle.
I will always push
a lack of regret
and awareness to
how good it really is.
You're more than welcome
to tell me how bad it is
or why you can't,
because or what,
but it's just not true.
Because if anybody ever did it,
then you can too.
Stop making excuses,
stop complaining,
nobody's listening.
They make pretend
they're listening,
the market doesn't care.
What you need to do is
make one person happy:
You. Then you make
everybody else happy.
You know why I like
making people happy?
'Cause I'm already happy.
And so I implore you
to take this last little rant
and really look at
your fucking face
and understand are
you doing the things
that are putting you
in a position to succeed,
not just in a business
world but in life.
Because it's super
important because boy
when you're happy in life,
you're fucking
business can roll,
and, so, I'm just
trying to figure it out.
I've been trying to
figure it out
in front of you for the last
seven, eight years.
Trying to figure out the unlocks.
EQ, IQ, self-awareness, hustle
I don't know what they are.
You know why?
'Cause like I told my man,
it's 330 different unlocks.
And so I'll go to all of them,
They're all tried and true
and one might hit you.
"Yeah, it was hard work
because I'm actually lazy."
"I talk a good game
but I'm full of shit."
Or it might be something else.
But fuck one
and so
you decided to sit?
You're into this? Right?
It's good, right?
This is some good shit.
You're gonna remember this?
- [Woman] I do.
- Good.
One fucking life.
One life, my friends.
One time.
And honestly, I'll leave you
with this because a lot
of you need it.
How you make your
money is more
important than how
much you make.
(light piano music)